we have a very exciting semi-final
at our hands here magnus carlsen against
jan
nepam nachi and that yes
i wanted to show you the first game from
their
thrilling match and without further ado
let's see how the game went
d4 knight f6 c4 g6
knight c3 bishop bishop g7 here is known
as the king's indian
but john the pumnachi's specialty is to
play
d5 which is known as the gordenfeld
defense so there are a bunch
of options for for white and the
grunfeld
i'm not going to show every single one
but for example
uh c65 as magnus does is one of the main
moves here
knight takes d5 and here he plays a um
a strange move he plays bishop d2 and
that move has gotten some popularity
recently
it is even possible to play knight a4
that is a move i've seen before
not such a such a dumb try e4
is the most common move where for
example
knight xc3 b takes c3 bishop g7
bishop c4 c5 knight e2 is heavy
theory and played a lot at top level
recently as well
like the candidates and the magnus
invitational the previous magnus tour
this opening was played quite frequently
so there are a lot of options knight f3
is another move here
c5 and for example bishop b5 is possible
bishop e3
a lot of moves i'm not going to go into
detail
let's see what magnus did here which is
bishop d2
and the line is very interesting and the
point is that he's going to take back
with the bishop
and the bishop gets a kind of a nice
placement there on
on c3 and eventually white can also
castle queen side and then start a
potential
attack so it is a very interesting line
and i'm sure
magnus had something prepared here so
bishop g7 is theory
e4 now black chooses to take on c3
uh it should be possible to play an ip62
where i would assume that
the most logical follow-up will be
bishop e3
and now white has this uh nice center
here
keep in mind that now c5 is not so
desirable because you can just simply
take it
and normally like we saw earlier here
after e4
takes takes c5 is one of the main moves
because it's not really possible to take
and
very often as the pieces develop
you can take on c5 but the pawn is so
vulnerable
that black will win it and then you will
have a slightly weak pawn on c3
kind of a common occurrence in the
grinfeld
but the story is entirely different when
you have a bishop on e3
like after knight b6 so a knight takes
c3 bishop takes c3
castles queen d2 magnus is going to go
for a
long castle and he's going to launch an
attack on
on the king side you can for example try
h4 h5 or simply just develop
with with knight f3 let's see what the
pawn energy does
he plays knight c6 knight f3
bishop g4 quite a logical continuation
here black wants to attack
the d4 pawn and he sort of does that
indirectly because this
he wants it now to take on f3 and then
take on d4
so d5 is played here by by magnus bishop
takes f3
bishop takes g7 kings takes g7 and g
takes f3 and we have a very interesting
position
black has a has a knight we have a
bishop
magnus has a bishop and this
these pawns are quite strong but black
has
decent control of the dark squares which
could be
very beneficial but black has to be
careful if black is not careful he can
end up in a worse position
very quickly so 95 attacking on f3
so so castles this is an
indirect way to protect f3 because if
knight
takes f3 we can play queen c3 or queen
f4
as well actually and the knight is
trapped but
here you're attacking both the knight
and king so it would not be possible to
take it
uh i can also say that if the queen c3
directly
f6 would be the way to to defend the
knight the only way but
it is enough where we have a complicated
position
but i like castles c6 that is also a
logical move black wants to open up the
position here and then try to
to attack white this is the reason why
magnus plays bishop h3 because he's now
attacking c8 which means that rook c8 is
no longer a possibility
and if black was going to take on d5 we
could simply play rook f3
and then maybe take with here we might
even play f4 but
to me it seems fairly okay to take with
uh
with the pawn because we get a decent
square on e6 with the
for the bishop and we also we still
prevent rook c8
which is of course very very important
so napalm actually plays queen king g8
which is
also a logical try because you do not
want to um
you want to get away from the pin
with queen c3 and if you don't have to
play f6
i would say that is a good thing because
then you still have control of this
important e6 square
and now if i am going to play queen c3
like magnus does here
he can still protect the rook with queen
d6
or queen c7 but the prominency he
doesn't play
any of those moves he plays queen b8
which is actually
a horrible horrible blunder and
if you want to you can pause the video
and you can see if you can find the
world champions continuation here
it is a very very good move
and it's the only way to get a winning
position
before we go into what happened again
queen c7 would have been
would have been much much better and the
point is
is that the tactic that we will see in
the game does not work
uh primarily because of this square here
is covered by the queen
it's quite important so the game could
for example continue king b1 and then
something like rook t8 and we have a
complicated position
which can go either way it's probably
roughly equal i think i'm just going to
say that it's unclear
chances for both sides i guess but in
the pannachi he blows it and he plays a
queen b8 and the killing move is d6
the important thing is that it would not
work directly to play f4
because if you do that i can play knight
g4 this was an
upon nash's plan all along
because if i now play queen f3 you can
then play knight of six
and black has decent pressure here
because if we take here
we can take back and this is very
dangerous for black queen
b5 and rook b8 come in quickly and queen
a4 eventually
and these pawns are quite weak so this
would be very good for black
but overlooks something very important
and another thing is that i cannot take
of course because then black takes on
the f4 with check
and the bishop is gone so
f4 wouldn't work but d6 is good enough
for a victory and the point is we block
this entire diagonal
and black is more or less forced to take
the pawn
so when he takes we then play f4 and the
knight is
absolutely trapped the d7 square
as i said is covered by the bishop so we
can simply take it
and that's why queen c7 was better
because we can simply we cannot take
tonight then
and uh yeah the game is uh over
technically
but uh nepam nachi he fights on with
rookie eight
magnus seeing that the knight is still
trapped he doesn't bother to take it yet
so he plays rookie one first
protecting the pawn so he can now take
later
the problem with taking immediately is
that after rook takes e5 or attacking e4
and rook c5 is a threat of course this
is no
issue but you might as well protect upon
an e4 first because the knight is
trapped anyway
a5 king b1 another waiting move by
magnus
so now rook c5 is also avoided a4
and the white simply takes the knight
rook takes and now f4
and black is absolutely doomed here
let's see what happened
rook c5 queen f6
attacking the pawn on d6 a3
v3 no need to allow any counter play
rook h5 and here the great great move
rook takes d6 and the point is that if i
now take the bishop
i can play rook t1 with rook dad coming
next which means that black is going to
lose his queen
if he tries to save his queen he is
checkmate
for example queen a7 rook d8 is made
instantly
so that wouldn't work and it's
impossible for black to say
just to guard that threat so napalm that
she plays
queen e8 but here the simple move or not
the simple move but the great move
bishop e6 wins the game instantly
and the point here is that um you
protect the pawn on e4
uh the problem with after queen eight if
i played rook d1 here
queen queen takes e4 would have been an
option
uh you do not want to allow that of
course so bishop e6 is a very nice way
to
guard uh that threat and after f takes
e6
rook d1 wins the game your same threat
as last time rook v8 and it's impossible
to avoid
because of this rook on h5 is completely
out of the game
and the palm that she simply resigned so
a very
very nice start by the world champion
very interesting opening too of course
you got some help by john the palm nachi
who
who made an unfortunate blunder there
with um
the queen b8 but it happens d6 is an
easy move to miss
uh i can then stress that the position
would have been
entirely unclear after queen c7 which is
uh the better move so i'm sure there was
something he didn't like with that move
let's see if uh f4 i guess he wanted
that knight g4 trap because here
it doesn't work that well because of
again d6 i think he saw d6 here i'm
pretty sure he saw this
that's why i played the queen b8 but
unfortunately d6 worked anyway
great start by magnus if you're upon
that she loses this match he still
can bounce back tomorrow let's see what
happens
and indeed stay tuned for more